so we have a really
dicey situation that is sort of the
coming together
of donald trump's voter suppression
tactics
and demeaning of vote by mail and
absentee ballots
donald trump's nomination of amy coney
barrett to the supreme court
which could directly impact what
ultimately happens
with many absentee ballots which could
ultimately impact the results of this
election particularly if it is close
we know that there are some democratic
wins
for both the presidency and the senate
which could
actually hinge on hinge on
absentee ballots and we already have
a snafu we could call it per the
intercept more than 100
000 absentee ballot requests have
already been invalidated in
multiple iowa counties in late august
judges ordered two iowa counties to
invalidate at least 64 000 ballot
requests
siding with donald trump the trump
campaign
brought a legal challenge the republican
party brought this legal challenge
they've been filing these lawsuits all
over the country
we told you they were ready with an army
of lawyers they are already deploying
them
about 50 000 voters in one county 14 000
voters in another county
will be informed that their request for
an absentee ballot won't count
and if you still want to vote by mail
you have to send a new form so you have
here
64 000 people plus 92
000 in a separate case in johnson county
which is where university of iowa is
expecting a more abiding leaning
electorate in that county
this is like a total of about 150 000
ballots now that we are talking about
they sent requests for an absentee
ballot
those have now been invalidated thanks
to this lawsuit
and many of those people may not know it
they may be sitting there
waiting for their absentee ballot to
arrive which may never
arrive unless they submit a new request
then early last week a fourth judge
sided with the trump campaign and the
republican party
upholding a recent law making absentee
voting
harder in iowa republicans push the law
in iowa over the summer it slows down
the process
for getting through and sending out the
absentee ballots
it makes it more difficult to get people
their ballots on time
what are democratic party officials
doing they're scrambling they're you
know always half a step
to two steps behind they need to now try
to contact people
who believe they have an absentee ballot
coming to them but actually don't and
they need to
figure out how do we communicate with
these people how do we get everybody
to request a new absentee ballot very
expensive
not impossible but very expensive so is
there any good news here
okay if i need to find some good news
the good news is
in most electoral map scenarios iowa is
not likely to be the deciding state it's
it's unlikely
that to biden getting to 270 electoral
votes
will hinge on the results in iowa
the bad news is they're going to pull
this and they're already pulling this in
many different states
so we have to understand the timelines
and we have to understand the deadlines
monday two days ago was the deadline to
register
in many states i i mean i'll give you
the list even though the deadline has
passed
ariz arizona arkansas florida georgia
hawaii
indiana kentucky louisiana mississippi
ohio
south carolina tennessee and texas did
you register because if you didn't it's
too late
okay if you're unsure if you're
registered google check voter
registration
your state and you will figure out how
to confirm your status
delaware is coming up on october 10th
you have until october 10th to register
in delaware
idaho is october 9th illinois was
yesterday
maryland is next monday i believe it is
missouri is today you have until today
to register in missouri new mexico is
yesterday new york is friday these dates
are coming the election is happening now
there's no more time to wait
vote.org has all of the information
about how to register
how to get an absentee ballot how when
and where to vote early everything you
need
we had early voting start this week in
california
iowa maine nebraska south carolina
if you're in those states you can start
to vote now
early voting in indiana and ohio started
yesterday
arizona starts today georgia starts
monday kentucky and texas
tuesday a bunch more next wednesday the
election is now my friends and this
is not the time to keep waiting for
something it is time to act right now
they are going to pull every dirty trick
that they can
they have lawyers ready to go they will
try to challenge absentee ballots
they will try to stop the counting of
absentee ballots a new poll
which i'll talk about tomorrow has
donald trump down
hope you're sitting 21 points it's just
one poll
but the numbers are getting very ugly
for trump and the uglier they get
the more all caps tweets we can expect
to see from him on twitter
and the more they are going to try to
use lawyers
and other subterfuge to steal this
election there is no more need to wait
to remove the insanity
the election is now yes we need
automatic voter registration
this this entire paradigm of registering
to vote and deadlines
disaster okay we need to fix it we need
to fix so many problems
but we have four weeks minus a day
right 27 days to go we have to vote
right now we will keep pushing this
make sure for the latest updates on
voting and how it's going
that you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show and while you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
one of our sponsors today is
barrymandering a
tabletop strategy game for two players
that simulates gerrymandering
gerrymandering of course is
when you manipulate electoral district
maps to benefit
a certain political party we talk about
it all the time
barrymandering has turned that into a
fun fast-paced game i've been having a
lot of fun playing this
with my girlfriend at home each round
takes about 15 minutes
easy to learn how to play but as i'm
finding out
difficult to master because there are so
many different ways to play
it's a great tool to explain
gerrymandering to someone who's not
familiar with the concept
it's great for two friends who love
politics and want to have fun
with an interesting tabletop game that
is unlike
anything you've ever played before i
know
anybody in my audience would have a
great time with this game and you can
even buy two copies of the game
to make a larger board for bigger games
go to davidpakman.com barry the link is
underneath this video
takes you to their amazon page and use
the code
important pacman2020 at checkout
for one dollar off